good afternoon I'd like to thank all of
you for participating in Colombia's
world leaders forum today we are honored
to welcome Herman Van Rompuy President
of the European Council I'd like to
begin by thanking Donald and Vera
blinken that the Donald and bureau
blinken european institute for
co-sponsoring this talk the blinkin
institute is the oldest organization in
the u.s. devoted to the study of europe
the institute's sophisticated
specialists have had a hand in shaping
the marshall plan nato Cold War security
and more recently the creation of the
European Union Columbia's world leaders
forum launched by president Bollinger a
decade ago reflects this university's
core values and our belief that only
through informed an open dialogue with
solutions emerged to society's most
difficult problems since 2003 Colombia
has been fortunate to host a tremendous
variety of presidents and prime
ministers from around the world this
week we are scheduled to have 11 heads
of state come to columbia the largest
number to speak here during the annual
September convening of the UN General
Assembly the Herman Van Rompuy the
former prime minister of Belgium was
chosen in 2009 by Europe's leaders to
become the first permanent president of
the european council last year he was
reappointed to what will be his second
and final term in his home country mr.
Van Rompuy held the posts of budget
minister and president of the
parliament's lower house while he is an
economist by training it certainly bears
mentioning the President Van Rompuy is
also a published poet with a book of
haiku to his credit that has been
translated from his native Flemish to
French German English and Latin and as
the European counts as president mr. Van
Rompuy leads a body comprised of the
heads of state of the 28 member
countries the council he leads his
responsible for setting the political
direction and priorities of the European
Union his job is undeniably a daunting
one demanding that consensus emerged
from a group defined by national and
ideological differences in recognition
of the importance of this work last year
President Van Rompuy accepted the Nobel
Peace Prize along with European
Commission President Jose Manuel Barroso
and European Parliament President Martin
Schultz for the European Union's
contributions to the advancement of
peace and reconciliation democracy and
human rights in Europe as the Nobel
Committee and many others have
recognized the striking contrast between
the pandemic violence the plagued Europe
through much of the 20th century and the
relative peacefulness of the years since
the formation of the European Union
warrant both the world's recognition and
a commitment to continuing on this path
because of this progress the continents
your economic challenges have been
allowed to move to center stage and they
are substantial the current period is
characterized by high unemployment and
very uneven growth across the nations of
the union must come to a close yet
turning the page on these problems
spawned by the global financial crisis
that remains elusive somewhat five years
later in addition the Union faces a
series of critical questions about its
membership ranging from Britain's future
in the EU to Turkey's inclusion
underlying each challenge is a tension
familiar to all of us since the
inception of the European Union and
before how can a confederation of
nations balance the demands of
sovereignty against the necessity of
sustained cohesive action can the
project of the united Europe succeed in
overcoming problems of historic
dimension and ensure a prosperous and
peaceful future the determined efforts
of President Van Rompuy and many others
give us hope that these challenges will
be met successfully the title of his
talk today is the state of the European
Union politics economy and democracy as
we listen it is worth keeping in mind
that Europe's problems aren't so
different from those we face here in the
United States for in a global society
problems rarely respect regional or
national boundaries as I said at the
outset of this introduction it is only
to open an honest discussion that new
remedies are developed to society's most
persistent problems we are honored that
Colombia is able to provide a forum for
just this kind of debate please join me
in giving a warm welcome to european
council president herman van rompuy
Oh rather than having president phone
room boy give a talk and a formal sense
what we wanted to do today is organized
a conversation i'm victoria de gracia
I'm a professor of history at Columbia
University I'm also the director of the
bleak and European Institute and this is
just an extraordinary occasion for us to
welcome you here into our own pantheon
you don't have to go to Rome anymore the
United States provides this even this
now one of the questions that comes up
almost right away for Americans who are
used to a strong executive elected
always in some ways in our face whether
you know we like him which I do or or
loathe him and it's a sense of the
faceless bureaucrat this is a kind of
American myth and I was very struck
friends in Japan and Belgium didn't do
mention that the first time that you
sort of gave yourself a very strong
public presence very distinct was indeed
publishing your book of haiku now was
that meant to be a political statement
we don't usually associate no I'm
chairing the European Council the
European Council gathering six seven
times a year the leaders of Europe
Presidents and Prime Minister's so I'm
chairing that meeting I'm not the
president of Europe I'm the president of
the european council makes a lot of
difference I'm elected all my life that
this time I've only 26 voters I was
reelected by 27 my successor will be
elected by 28 and that's all
that's all so you can compare this
function with the functions of the
President of the United States or any
other function call in my own country
I'm a hero in my own country they call
me president of Europe I I never say the
opposite if somebody is somebody say
something positive on you never
contradicted it is so rare so so low
that you have to cherish that moment but
sometimes I think there's been confusion
here because there's also President
Barroso the President of the European
Commission and then we say eyes or
rivalry is this all necessary what
what's the difference all that that
that's in some way it's it's rather easy
to understand each country but we are
not the country but each country has an
executive power a president in in the
United States avoid a head of state
let's call it a head of states as a
better they have a some kind of
government in most of European country
and never parliament in you in the
United States you have a presidential
system so but in most of European
countries you have two three of them so
the European Council in some way is has
the functions of a head of state and I
am chairing a collective body but that
collective body is as a group the head
of state the European Commission is the
government and as every country but
again we are not a state there we have a
parliament so we have the tree functions
and that's not unusual this very common
very common I know that those who try to
make a carriage a caricature of the
European Union sure they say it is very
complicated this very easy let's say
that I'm more a president president
barroso is more a prime minister and
then yelled
as simple as that one of the problems
that know that you face particularly now
this European crisis and there's been to
call it your skepticism doesn't do
justice to the problems now is you know
what is your relationship with public
opinion how do you you know extend your
effort to create consensus is it
possible to reach out to a so-called
European public opinion or do you really
feel obliged still I mean so far as you
want to be a very very capable which you
are to work basically to respect that
you are in a sense pointed by the the
members yeah I'm appointed by the Prime
Minister's and by the president's so my
first job is to get an agreement among
those leaders and our decision-making
process is quite complicated because we
need unanimity if the president of
Romania is not agreeing we have not an
agreement so we have to work until the
27 now 28 agree but this is dis quite a
complicated task and some have even a
problem to agree with themselves so I
have the final agreement of course I
come from a country where compromise is
our second nature I chair a government
with six parties can imagine six parties
no way of the only 27 and egg young I
can go even further most of those
countries have coalition government's so
when I have the consent of a prime
minister I have the consent of a
coalition in that particular country so
when we reach an agreement for instance
on the European budget which we did
actually it is an agreement among 60
parties all over Europe all over Europe
so we have to work hard and that's my
core business so physically how do you
do this do you
tug on sleeves you have your I'm leading
good shape for a man a man of 66
confirmation I can compliment me no it
is it is of course a difficult task and
so where your question was how do you
reach out to European public opinion I
would say this is not my main task that
is more the task of the prime ministers
and presidents because there they are
elected directly most of them by by
their electorate in their member states
and they have to persuade them to
convince the public opinions that the
agreements we reach collectively of the
good ones also for their country and
that that's part of my job on and their
job they have to prove in each of their
countries that what was decided is in
the interest of Latvia but also in the
interest of the European Union or in the
interest of Germany and in the interest
of the European Union so those interests
as to coincide there's of course the
overall European interest but of course
the voters are interested in what what
is the be for me what is the added value
for me for me in Latvia or in Germany
and then we have to prove that they're
also good for them right I sense that
there isn't some real compatibility
between the Haiku in this effort to
create these extraordinary combinations
and let me just read one but call
Brussels different colors tongues towers
and gods I searched my way very very
elegant and meaningful the haiku is
something very simple that's only 17
syllables is that experience in nature
of related to the seasons and
you can you have to express yourself in
the in simple words and something that
you easily can understand so it is a
some kind of antidote room for all the
complicated issues I have to deal with
so I am fleeing in some way to haiku by
the way I will publish my second book in
October so I recommend it strongly well
look forward to launching this ok if you
want your middle America more rabar
battis questions so with the ending of
the pre-election political uncertainty
with Angela Merkel's resounding victory
question is what next it seems that
there are a lot of issues addressing the
economic crisis but also the political
architecture of Europe which have been
held in abeyance so I was wondering
review what's next after she forms her
cabinet or maybe even before what kinds
of signals are being sent what kinds of
agenda do you see now coalescing as the
election let me say first that the
victory of Angela Merkel is quite
exceptional because in a European in a
crisis economic crisis a eurozone crisis
in a recession getting a third mandate
is almost unprecedented I give you an
example I was elected or appointed let
it to your evaluation in november two
thousand nine x 26 European leaders I
was myself at that time Prime Minister I
voted for myself but there was not a
real fault and was a consensus but from
those 26 only 9 left
in the European counts most of them have
to leave not because they are performing
badly but they had to take measures
which are highly unpopular and in some
way they were punished by the electorate
here angular macro succeeded in winning
the election for the first time and as I
said in the midst of a crisis and really
unusual by the way she did it without
spin doctors without a huge
communication strategy without lying she
did it in our own way and this is a
cultural phenomenon of the first degree
also that you can be elected in you in a
very important country as Germany by 60
million voters by electorate of 60
million voters without using all those
means and let's say and the media state
in which we are living on the media
society in which we are living right
that's putting aside okay I think it's
absolutely right to give her this credit
for this sincerity her integrity but
some could argue that it's a vote for
austerity for Germany and against Europe
so is what you call it austerity you can
also call it sound public finances
that's another way of expressing it and
you can maybe in a short term yeah now
you're sincere in the medium of the long
term yeah but you can't you can't have
in a sustainable way a sound economy
without sound public finances and with a
high competitiveness so and that we
discover too late we launched the euro
are common
currency without realizing from the
start on that if you have if you need if
you have a common currency you need also
common policies and you need sound
policies structurally sound in public
finance and in the economy on
competitiveness so what we are doing now
in Europe is more inspired by a
long-term objectives instead of
short-term we showed also now
flexibility in in our fiscal policies
giving countries now leeway to achieve
the three percent target at three
percent deficit target what later on and
originally scheduled so we show some
flexibility but on the long term we
agreed not not with 10 but with 27 28
countries together we agreed that we are
aiming in each of our countries towards
balanced budgets not tomorrow but let's
say over a period of five six seven
years that not a German policy that's a
commonly agreed policy and it is
completely an S&S st if you have a
common currency and so there is a
misunderstanding all the decisions in
the european union in the european
council are taken by the 27 28 countries
to gather together for some countries
play an important role and some even
more than others but at the end of the
day at the end of my meeting i have to
get the agreement of all of them and we
did it all the time during the last
three years but in this case in the case
of germany has a valence its strength in
the market that is far greater than
being one amongst equals so the question
comes down and I know this is something
you're dealing with all the time can you
imagine a different balance between
austerity and solidarity such that we've
been looking at up to now I mean these
are questions that Americans are
debating all the time for the United
States but also on the case of Europe as
well there's too little solidarity too
little marshall plan to little prospects
for different kind of transfer a
different kind of investment structure
among the european states and that you
know you've got to restructure the
architecture to enable different kinds
of decision-making is I also took your
question in my view on austerity i call
it more sound public finances of the
longer term on solidarity and now all
the I know the issue I come from a
country where solidarity is in the heart
of the public debate are the Flemish
people pay too much for the balloons or
not and when you are only with two in in
a country you always know who is
receiving and who is those who made the
donations so we you're always we use the
word transfer so for me I was used to
that the kind of debate in Europe but
again here as far as solidarity is
concerned the European Union until five
six years ago was a win-win situation
turn yeah we created a common market and
we have the biggest common market in the
world 500 million people with high
purchasing power one of the highest
standard living standards in the world
so we created this because that creates
more competition that creates also what
schumpeter called creative destruction
but overall it was a win-win situation
and then we launched for not for all the
countries but for some countries a
common currency not only a common market
but also a common currency the euro the
eurozone
and in the beginning it was also a
win-win situation it changed with the
financial crisis started hearing at the
other side of on this side of the
Atlantic and then some of our structural
problems of structural problems in some
of our member states came to the surface
then we discovered that part of the
economic growth from the last ten years
was artificial was based on public debt
and on project that I'm where to correct
this in those countries who were living
beyond their means that you correct it
the people is not guilty for they were
simply badly rude mal governor as the
Italians would say but we had to correct
this and then we said the European Union
you your go to a difficult period we
have to take measures in terms of fiscal
consolidation restoring competitiveness
and so on and by the way you have no
access to financial markets anymore
because we are not inspiring confidence
confidence enough and we said that we
will help you we will help you and so we
met we put at the disposal of those
countries 500 billion euros this is what
we call taxpayers money it is not a gift
it is alone but there is always a risk
of people consider that there is a risk
taxpayers are considered that there is a
risk but we did it also Germany did it
it's huge contributor so in the first
period of the European Union in the
common market and in the first decade of
the common currency we there was no need
for solidarity so you can't say there is
no less solidarity than before there was
no need for solidarity during a long
time and now we read solidarity
certainly in terms of the
half I mean there was a lot younger is
about earlier period but but the
European budget I was not bothered you
with all the details of our low-cost
structural European budget is one
percent of European GDP sure what do you
not were you the public expenditures in
Europe overall so local expenditures
regional expenditures state expenditures
European expand your social security
overall is on average in each of our
member states fifty percent 50 of the
gdp the European budget is one percent
of GDP so there is a part of solidarity
in the European budget tour but let's
say for 0.4 0.5 that that I don't call
real solidarity but now for the India
razon crisis we put in a disposal those
countries under pressure and under
program as we called a package of five
hundred billion so we showed really
solidarity if was this easy to obtain no
because that they had to go each of the
member states and each of the leaders to
their public opinion and say we have a
common currency it is in your interest
that the Euro remains stable and that
the Euro remains to cool and that we
keep that currency so this in your
interest but in the meantime we have to
help some countries and some of the
voters in those country said why do we
need to help the Greeks the Irish and
the others so there were legitimate
questions and although that there was
that kind of euro criticism the leaders
defended the option of solidarity don't
underestimate this effort and some pay
the high price in the elections for this
there is much more political courage
than most people still your Nobel Peace
Prize speech you spoke of your father's
generation experiencing the the war and
fathers lamented
the death of their children in some ways
I was with the same voice you were very
worried about a new lost generation that
is the youth of Europe they needs you
know not an employment not in education
not in training as and others too are
saying this may be the biggest problem
that this is a generation growing up
with very very high unemployment with
enormous changes in technology going on
could you tell us some about what the
European Council has been doing I know
it and attended supported a summit in
july two thousand thirteen again you
know you get the car purrs The Economist
magazine thing it's not enough it's not
enough this is a huge question I know
it's a question certainly that we talked
about in the United States perhaps with
perhaps with not the same clarity but
then there's also a different so could
you think about that with us for some
yeah first of all all what we did the
ultimate a the ultimate goal is
employment is chops we are not saving
the euro because it is the euro we are
not embarking on fiscal consolidation
because we like it but we because we
think that this is best at the end for
prosperity and for jobs but it is a
long-term objective and you may not
forget that in two or three years time
the confidence of people were shaken in
very very deeply first of all there was
the problem of the bank's people who had
full confidence in the financial sector
and although suddenly discovered that
banks can collapse they didn't collapse
in Europe but there was this track and
then two years later
there was the crisis of the currency of
course people never thought that this
currency could be under pressure on the
track and you has to understand that
this created the crisis of confidence
and now now I'm not now speaking not on
the good of the countries under program
as we call it Greece Ireland Portugal in
some ways pain now I speaking about
let's say the Western European the
northern European country some big
crisis of confidence when there is a
lack of confidence people don't consume
and don't invests so we have to restore
confidence first and that's what we did
the existential chat on the eurozone is
over a year ago right now in September
the still the discussion was going on
not if the eurozone would collapse that
was for sure the only discussion was
about the date this discussion is
completely open so we save the euro we
save the euro zone the eurozone is not
under existential chat anymore but there
is a time lag between the restoration of
confidence and the beginning of spending
by consumers and investors the beginning
of economic growth and there is a time
lag between economic growth and jobs and
employment it took more time than we
thought the crisis was deeper and it
took us more time to overcome the crisis
so we have now in 26 27 countries which
one country missing Cyprus but in 26 27
countries we have we will have positive
economic growth next year and we will
have the beneficial impact of it on the
employment market a little bit later
but we can't wait and that's why we said
we have to the meantime we have to take
specific measures at the level of the
Member States and at the level of the
Union and the eurozone to combat youth
unemployment and the aim is to give to
every youngster after having left school
or be getting unemployed to give him in
four months time a training and
apprenticeship or an offer for a job to
use task we we already reached out to
800,000 young people in Europe with
those programs how did you do that
through the net daily the national
governments national governments now the
best competence is national government
we are supporting this from the European
budget with eight billion a week eight
billion euros but this main may need
task of national governments or in some
countries regional governments or local
governments but just one detail and is
don't underestimate a problem not at all
and I'm not trying to downplay it but
you have to have a sharp look also to be
statistics i know that in some of the
countries there you have used an
employment level of fifty or sixty
percent but if you have a closer look to
it if you only count those who are not
employed not in an education not in
training for instance in some of the
countries with an unemployment rate on
the millenniums of fifty percent it is
eighteen percent which is already huge
but not to the extent that those figures
try to show so it is a huge problem the
ultimate goal of otwell what we are
doing is gross unemployment but via
specific targeted measures we try to
give a perspective for those young
people in the meantime there was an also
increase in the Erasmus you know the
student mobility yeah that was already
before the crisis that
a structured program so that people can
can travel all over over Europe and to
know each other of course with the the
means of the cheap right here tiktik
it's that and so this is completely
different compared to my youth which is
very close change of topic is very
worried many ways about gas is the use
of gas and Syria intervention the civil
war in Syria the European Union has been
less should we say conspicuous then it
was let's say in time of Libya and I
wanted if you could let us understand
the thinking about how to provide what
kind of support to end the civil war
because you can't compare Libya would
share no two completely different
countries located in different parts of
the world we took our responsibilities
in Libya Gaddafi was at the brink of
invading Benghazi and we live in Europe
under the trauma of serenity so that is
this town in in former Yugoslavia were
thousands of people man boys most of
them were killed by by extremists and
when we have not forgotten this and we
saw that this could happen also in
Benghazi that's why the French the
British and helped by a lot of other
Europeans and supported by the Americans
took this initiative of launching an
attack
on Libya in march two thousand eleven so
that this would there would be no second
Severin Itza in our neighborhood Syria
is a totally as I said a totally
different world much more complicated in
the most dangerous region of the world
unfortunately the United Stated Nations
Security Council couldn't find a
political solution for this problem
during two years one of the paradoxes of
the last week's is that after this
inhumane crime attacked by chemical
weapons after this there are no more
possibilities apparently and hopefully
for an understanding between the main
players in the UN Security Council as
link on one set in his famous Gettysburg
be that these dead shall not have died
in vain you always die in vain but I
still remember this speech and knew it
by heart when I was a young man but that
this chemical attack and all the people
killed in this chemical attack can
create something positive also and if
there is now an understand where it can
be an understanding between the main
players this can be the beginning of a
process not only on chemical weapons but
also on the lasting solution for the
Syrian crisis and European Union is very
supportive for this approach we defend
it from the start on a political
solution there is no military solution
whatsoever for the Syrian crisis but of
course there is a strong we need a
political will and those who have our
close to the government of Syria and
those who are more close to the
opposition have to urge those who are
fighting to come to Geneva and to talk
and negotiate do you think that the
Europe is more divided than than it was
on Libya that end in Libya it was not
simple because some of the most
important countries were in the
beginning not convinced after
discussions in the European Council by
the way and the week after this European
Council in march two thousand eleven we
were are all on the same line here on in
Syria we defend it all the 28th a
political solution and even if some of
them thought on a military attack I have
to say that the fifth of September in
Vilnius Lithuania the 28th Minister of
Foreign Affairs had agreed on a common
position a common position saying that
we have to give to wait first on the
report of the UN inspectors and the way
that we have to work in the UN Framework
I know that afterwards the events
developed in another way but in the
fifth of September we had a common
position in the midst of the debate on
military attack but European Union is
not only active politically European
Union is the biggest donor for
humanitarian straight and we are
providing now 1.5 billion help as boards
for the people for the government's in
Turkey in Jordan and in in Lebanon and
we we stand ready to do to do more
because we have now two million refugees
outside Syria if the trend of the last
month's continue we will have three and
a half million by Christmas and let's
hope that we find in the meantime Apple
it
solution for the crisis but on the
humanitarian side the European Union and
its member states are the biggest donors
by the way we are the biggest donor for
development 8 in the world half of
development 8 in the world is provided
by the European Union and its member
states truly soft power because what it
is soft power yes we are not the florin
nightingales but we are simply helping
people and I I am pretty sure how
history will judge us I probably don't
have time for more than one question
drive oh my glasses like him sign
language back there but okay so this
sounds like a very boring question the
transatlantic Alliance and especially
interested in the effort to launch new
trade agreements now it strikes me that
is that's not about lowering tariffs
because tariffs between Europe and the
US pretty low but rather about
regulatory differences and certainly one
regulatory difference has to do with the
whole question of how very big
organizations whoracle Google etc used
surveillance and collect big data and I
wanted if you had thoughts about the way
big data is collected and no cetera I
don't think that this part of the tea
tip negotiations but I have sufficient
problems not elaborate on this issue but
the European Union is not the only
target I listened this morning carefully
to the brazilian president I will i
would say that no European leader would
pronounce that
of speech but there is a lot of
uneasiness metal for the world about all
this but let's say we have we have set
up to working groups European Union and
the United States clarifying this topic
in one of those European Commission is
involved in the other is the only the
member states are involved so we are
still in speaking terms on this issue
but it is a highly sensitive issue in in
our countries and don't forget that some
of our member states left only 20 years
ago systems which in which everybody was
spying everybody of course this is not
comparable with what what what was the
usual practice in those member states
but there is still there are still the
remainders of that feeling so it is this
kind of of problem is particularly
sensitive in again and between the
United States and the European Union we
are trying to clarify this so that we
are both of us more at ease but as I
said the European Union is not the only
target in the world silver rupee I think
we should open up to questions we have a
just a wonderful audience here and then
at the very end I think you might want
to you know wrap this up with lots of
considerations so see how questions and
then let's see so I will just start in
and perhaps collect a couple would you
yes do you want to speak Mike I think
young my understanding is you go to the
mic and speak that you probably have to
line up in fact so why don't I saw her
hand first
didn't understand in the meantime would
you is that old man these are the line
now goes out the door go ahead sir yeah
my name is Jim French and Belgian
citizen we do out one a small question
regarding as an MC kees and human rights
many injuries talk about human rights
violation in detecting the detention of
asylum seekers in southern European
countries particularly southern European
countries and I was wondering what does
the you can counsel tries to do to
rectify the situation and you're
speaking about the tension of some
asylum seekers yes I don't know if you
are referring to a particular situation
a particular country or also but the
tension is a competence of the Member
States we in the Union we agreed finally
on let's say minimum standards for
asylum seekers so the conditions which
we accept them or not accept or not
accepting them in in the country but you
know because you are french belgium that
those issues are in the heart of the
public debate in each of the countries
so the member states are very keen to
keep this among their competencies it is
already quite an achievement that we get
an agreement on minimum standards not of
detention but for the the way we we
accept applications for us Alf asylum
seekers or not but for the Indian
detention it is a competence of the of
the Member States I'm not avoiding the
problem I tried to describe
oh ET s'en thank you so much for
speaking with us today back to the trade
deal I was curious what do you think
would be the major benefits from the you
US trade deal currently being negotiated
but trait is the biggest engine for
growth for jobs in general and if the
two main trading bloc's in the world can
agree as you said on more harmonizing
non-tariff standards and regulations
then and this is beneficial for trade
for half of the world economy so trait
is an engine for growth you don't need
fiscal deficits you don't need spending
money but by reorganizing trade and
having more trade flowers among those
big economies as the economy of the
European Union United your cricket you
create more prosperity and more jobs
that's the big game thank you thank you
yes sir my name is jacob johnson and i'm
a freshman in columbia college and my
question is regarding the unification of
europe clearly over the last few decades
Europe has become more and more United
and my question for you is whether you
will support or resist further attempts
to unify Europe some even talk about a
United States of Europe and what
positive benefits do you see of unifying
Europe further in terms of dealing with
issues like corruption and distribution
of wealth and further dealing with
climate change and what negative
ramifications do you see like
maintaining diversity and how would you
deal with those negative ramifications
thank you so first of all Europe is
still expanding we accepted Croatia the
28 member states in July and we have
countries we are which are candidate
countries
hopefully with some of them we start
very soon negotiations with some of them
we are even negotiating and it's a very
very happy team why because it shows
that we are still attractive the
European Union by the way is still sexy
because a lot of people want to join the
club the President of the European
Council de sexe that's for sure but also
the European Union so that that's what
we are still expounding but we are also
deepening the unification process
especially in the eurozone I mentioned
it briefly we we organized a common
currency so we set up a common currency
but we forgot that we need also a lot
more common policies in the last three
years during the eurozone crisis we had
to build completely new architecture to
have a stronger governance of the
eurozone collectively so we are
deepening the integration in the
eurozone not all over the Union but in
the eurozone 17 18 countries now so we
are widening and deepening the
integration step by step don't ask me
what the union will be in 10 20 or 30
years that's not my problem we'll see if
it will never be the United States of
Europe never because each of our
countries has his own history his own
identity and they are they will never
give it up we also have 24 languages in
the in Europe so it will never be
comparable with the United States of
America we will we will have a union but
it will always be
a very particular one a very specific
one adapted to our history and our
geography thank you hi my name is Bo
caitanya I'm a second year MBA student
from spain master difference yeah
although i did my erasmus in brussels so
I'm I will always be grateful to the
European Union for that and my question
is regarding Spain what is your view on
the structural changes that the
government is is is making in Spain and
do you think they will be enough or are
you or would you like to ask them
identify for another round of of more
structural reforms you can imagine if I
make comments on what's happening in
each of our members that I can give up
my job immediately
but the formal government Spanish
government on the leadership of charlie
Louisa Petero and the current government
of Mariano Rajoy made tremendous effort
structural efforts to rebalance the
Spanish economy to get rid of huge
public but huge private debt and so
Spain is a good example in some way of
artificial growth during the first years
of the eurozone they have to correct
this with a very high price very high
price so I in some way I admire their
courage although there cannot cannot
show results yet and because met also in
Spain we see the first clear indications
of renewed economic growth not yet on
the labour market but Spain is a good
example of a readjustment process a very
harsh one but an inevitable one but I
know the sufferings of the people there
were very badly rules during years and
years and the current government's have
the very difficult task to do corrective
but don't ask me what they have to do
and make an assessment in a detailed
assessment of what they have done I only
say they were very courageous in very
difficult circumstances hi Kate banner
in Austin I'd like to return to the
issue of the us-eu T tip in particularly
you identify some of the benefits that
could come out of agreeing upon
increased trade can you identify some of
the sticking points in reaching such an
agreement and how the US and EU can sort
of work their way through
I'm the President of the European
Council and really I'm not a candidate
to negotiate that count of agreement I
leave this to my compatriots au
commission of the hood happened also to
be a Belgium ready to compromise as
always we may even try to find
compromises when even when it's not
needed but that is his task I know that
our there are big and difficult issues
they are now in an exploratory phase and
I think in 3-4 months time we will see
what the real difficulties are the
optimists say that we can find solutions
for the problems within a period of two
years we'll see if this is doable but we
have a lot of issues and I will not go
into any detail a lot of issues which
will need really the art of compromise I
have not answered your question I know
it but it is a very ambitious
negotiations but it is doable hello my
name is cody smith I'm a master's
student of negotiation my question is
what is your vision of Europe over the
next 50 or 100 years I have no vision
for the for the upcoming I dl alpha know
even that not there's a famous German
Chancellor is that those who have
visions have a problem
taking their medicine okay let me take
one more here rear yes sir hello
afternoon sir first off I want to thank
you for coming to time I your trip to
come and visit and speak with us my
question regards Turkey prior to your
position as president of the european
council your views on Turkey were well
documented in light of events both the
Turkish government's response to protest
earlier this year as well as events in
Europeans near neighborhood in which
turkey is a large player i was wondering
i'm curious whether your opinion on the
issue of turkey in full membership has
changed substantially from before so
turkey is a candidate country that was
decided in 1999 we start negotiations
with turkey i think in 2005 or 2006 and
there's those negotiations where blocked
I think one year or two years ago the
last chapter that was open to us under
Belgium presidency and that is the
second half of 2010's out during almost
two years the process of negative of
negotiation was interrupted I went to
Turkey in May had good talks with the
Prime Minister and with the president of
the republic government and there were
good hopes that we can open one or two
chapters in the negotiation chapters is
a a specific topic on which we try to
agree because countries has to comply
with targets in in order to to get an
agreement on on accession and so there's
this chapter we hope that we could open
one or two chapters in the upcoming
month and then came the incidents you
mentioned and this made the complex
relationship even more complex
but we decided in the European Council
of the end european cars of the end of
june to open one additional chapter
under certain conditions but that those
conditions can be met so that we decided
to open a chapter chapter 22 so that the
process of negotiations can start again
but turkey as I said it is not a
candidate country as all others but it
is important that the negotiations can
restart because with that kind of
country very successful economically
compared to many other countries a
democratic country it is important that
we keep that close relationship we will
see where the negotiations will bring us
if we can conclude this but keeping in
close contact under the form of
negotiations is absolutely key and so
I'm personally strongly in favor of it
and I went to to Ankara in May to to
push it and to give it an additional
impetus good evening my name is David
I'm a Spanish graduate student here at
Columbia and my question for you also
regards Spain and it was the position on
the European Council on the referendum
for Catalunya to gain independence from
spain and what would be the rep
recursion if it did gain independence in
2014 I learned the harsh lesson in
politics never answer hypothetical
questions never because as we there is
no end it if this happened what would be
your your your answer and so on so i
hope that spain remains a united country
and they have their own procedures also
constitutional procedures also on
referenda
and everybody has to respect those
constitutional provisions but in general
I said I don't consider that eventuality
of breaking up of one of the member
states I can say this more easily
because I come from a country where
separatism is for some parties an issue
and I refuse to go deeper into that
topic because I'm also for my country
I'm strongly in favor to keep the
country as it is federal state a
deepened federal state even more than
that but still a united country and full
member of the European Union hi thank
you for coming today my name is MIA and
the senior at the college I you
mentioned that a lot of countries still
want to join the European Union and
that's a good sign but there are
countries that want to leave the
European Union and I'm referring to the
possibility of the of Britain
withdrawing from the european union
could you address this what the
implications would be for the European
Union if Britain were to withdraw
there's you made men one mistake is that
some countries want to leave it just
broke again no that is they there are
there are some some people in Britain
who want to leave but not a country as a
whole not at all I know it is an issue
of course it is an issue but we'll see
the disease to the British to decide
they have to make up their mind there
are there are some proposals for
organizing a referendum but it is after
the elections
and then we have we have to first to see
who is winning the elections and then
you can speak again if needed on on a
referendum but if you ask me what you're
strong but my strongest which is of
course Britain is full part of the
European Union playing a very important
role in European Union cooperating with
us also in this difficult period we
agreed with all the member states
including the United Kingdom on a
European budget which was not an easy
task at all and they are cooperating
with us on deepening and strengthening
the eurozone and from time to time we
need the votes also for those not
belonging to the eurozone because we
have to to change laws for the 27 so
that we can apply them to the 17 of the
18 of the eurozone but we need the
support of the Europe of the of the
United Kingdom and they gave us that
support so they are a full member
cooperating fully also in those
difficulties and I believe but that's
the British people to make up their mind
that is in the interest of the British
people to remain a full member of the
European Union half of their exports
have as destination the other members of
the European Union that's enough as an
indication how important the union is
for the British economy thank you thank
you i think is the XM over would you
like to say some words
dark woods I've not prepared any
statement but it was a pleasure to be
here a pleasure to address this audience
in this very European style building and
as you said it is like the pantheon but
the pantheon is for the death here we
are in the midst of life the youth and
thank you everyone of you thank you so
much for this very generous conversation
was just very very grateful and we're
going to welcome you back after because
probably you aren't going to be
appointed for a third term that right so
we have another occasion here good thank
you
ladies and gentlemen please remain